hello dr. Wallach County today fine
thank you how can we help you thank you
for taking my call I'm actually calling
for my brother Mike
he lives in New Hampshire and he's 64
years old 510 180 pounds and he has some
history of that problem but he's been
using treadmill and the hang-up device
which could help that yes he has just
started to system yes and his fingers
and he has he's been retired for five
years but prior to that he operated
heavy equipment which would mostly be
snow plowing etc and he had five years
ago he had surgery for a tear on one
shoulder which is fine today and next
week he is scheduled for the other
shoulder which is the complete tear and
he's probably going to go through with
the surgery but I was recommending that
he asked about your products so that he
can start the healing process well never
advice okay good well you know whether
he feels good in a week or so and says
oh maybe I should think about the
surgery for 90 days before we do it okay
he might want to consider that certainly
Charmaine are you there
I'm here okay 180 pounds has a history
of back problems shoulder problems and
you know there's a very typical
middle-aged guys 50 to 65 they start
breaking down especially and your
husband a shower you know ran heavy
equipment and big trucks and things like
that and so he's been taking this stuff
so what would you suggest for Ana for
her brother well for those issues I
would suggest he takes two healthy bone
and joint packs and then he can add just
yeah you know add the trauma oil to the
CM cream that does come with the packs
and he can also add the CM plus capsule
soft gels
okay very good that sure is exactly
right Anna do get him off all the bad
foods the fried foods processed meats
oils and glutens wheat bread ran out so
he can absorb more efficiently and also
give her the inflammatory stuff
but also HR said two healthy bone and
joint packs full dose everything twice a
day except for the gluco gel you'll be
able to there's enough in there he'll we
have been able to take five three times
his 85 at breakfast five at lunch and
dinner and if she said the trommel I'll
get to those little bottles the world
ten ml bottles of Cromwell from her
ancient legacy Roman therapy oral
division it's a blend of oils has
analgesic or pain relieving effects put
five drops of the trommel oil and every
teaspoon of the same cream heating
applied to his shoulders to his back to
the knees hips elbows wrists any place
he has these kinds of problems and it's
imperative to stay away from the bad
stuff and this is a lifetime deal we
want him to maximize his absorption of
nutrients and parts wear out just like
cars you can't say well I'm eating well
that's not good enough
that'd be like putting dirt from Texas
in your Lamborghini and hoping there's
oil and that dirt from Texas cuz it's
dirt from Texas not good enough put all
in your car you take the 90 essential
nutrients